welcome back to understanding Quantum information and computation my name is John wattrus and I'm the technical
director for education at IBM Quantum this is the 11th lesson of the series and it's the third lesson in the
third unit which is on the general formulation of quantum information this lesson is about measurements which represent an
interface between Quantum and classical information when a measurement is performed on a system while it's in a
Quantum State classical information is extracted revealing something about that Quantum State and generally changing or
destroying that state in the process in a simplified formulation of quantum information which was discussed
in the first unit of the series we typically restrict our attention to projective measurements including the
simplest type of measurement standard basis measurements it is however possible to generalize the notion of a measurement
and that turns out to be a pretty useful thing to do in this lesson we'll talk about measurements in full generality
including how they're described in mathematical terms and how they fit into the general formulation of quantum
information toward the end of the lesson we'll also take a look at a couple of fundamental Notions connected with measurements namely Quantum State
discrimination and Quantum State tomography so let's get started here is an overview of the
lesson as we often do we'll start with the basics including a couple of different but equivalent ways that we
can describe measurements in math mathematical terms in particular we can describe measurements by collections of matrices
and we can also describe them as channels which I alluded to in the previous lesson we'll also discuss partial
measurements or in other words measurements that are performed on just one part of a larger compound
system then we'll move on to neymark theorem which is a fundamental fact concerning measurements that basically
says that General measurements can always be implemented in a simple way that's reminiscent of Stein spring
representations of channels in short General measurements can always be implemented by first introducing an
initialized workspace system then performing a unitary operation and finally performing a standard basis
measurement on the workpace system this turns out to be pretty easy to prove and we'll see how that goes and
we'll also see how this connects to so-called non-destructive measurements which I'll describe finally in the last part of the
lesson we'll discuss Quantum State discrimination and Quantum State tomography we'll begin with mathematical
descriptions of measurements measurements provide us with an interface between Quantum and
classical information when a measurement is performed on a system while it's in some Quantum State classical information
about that Quantum state is extracted in addition the quantum state is generally changed or possibly
destroyed completely initially we'll focus our attention on so-called destructive measurements where
a Quantum State goes in and just classical information comes out so there's no specification of the
postmeasurement quantum state of the system that was measured intuitively speaking we can imagine that a destructive measurement
destroys whatever system was measured so its state after the measurement takes place isn't
specified this doesn't literally mean that physical devices are necessarily destroyed it's just a mathematical
description and it's a very useful one because it helps to keep things simple and to focus in on the essential
mathematical aspects of measurements there are in particular two equivalent ways to describe destructive
measurements which I mentioned during the overview of the lesson one way to describe a destructive
measurement is by a collection of matrices where in particular we have one Matrix for each possible measurement
outcome a second way to describe a destructive measurement is by a channel where the
input is the state of whatever system is being measured and the output is always a diagonal density Matrix which we can
interpret as a description of a probability distribution over the possible classical measurement
outcomes the two descriptions are equivalent and that's pretty useful because it allows us to pick whichever description is more convenient in a
given situation we'll also talk about non-destructive measurements where in addition to a classical measurement
outcome postmeasurement Quantum state of the system that was measured is also
specified non-destructive measurements are important and they arise frequently but there is a sense in which they're
somehow not as fundamental as destructive measurements in mathematical terms in particular as it turns out
non-destructive measurements can always be described as compositions of channels and destructive measurements and with
we'll see how that works a bit later in the lesson now let's take a look at how measurements meaning destructive
measurements can be described as collections of matrices throughout this discussion we'll suppose that X is a system that's
being measured and just for the sake of Simplicity we'll make a couple of assumptions first we'll assume that the
classical State set of X consists of the integers from 0 to n minus one for some positive integer n and the possible
outcomes of the measurement are the integers from 0 to M minus one again for some positive integer M there doesn't
need to be any relationship between the numbers n and M they're both arbitrary positive integers and of course we could replace
these sets by arbitrary classical State sets if we wanted to do that first let's recall how projective
measurements work which we first talked about back in the third lesson of the series given that we're assuming that
the measurement outcome are the integers from 0 to n minus one we describe a projective measurement by a collection
of projections Pi 0 through Pi M minus one that's sum to the identity Matrix and these matrices all have rows and
columns corresponding to the classical states of X or in other words these are all n byn
matrices if x is in a Quantum State that's described by a Quantum State Vector s then each possible measurement
outcome a appears with probability equal to the ukian norm squ of Pi a multiplied
to the vector s the ukian norm squar of any Vector is equal to the inner product of that
Vector with itself so we get the expression that's shown on the screen and we can simplify that just a
little bit by using the fact that Pi a is a projection so multiplying it to itself doesn't do
anything and finally we can rewrite the expression we've obtained in a slightly different way using the cyclic property